so the MRNA vaccines they're not safe
they're not effective and they're not
necessary I implore the government
to Halt they use immediately Andrew
bridgen had already become known as an
outspoken vaccine conspiracy theorist
just last month the MP for Northwest
leicestershire used a debate in the
House of Commons to make a series of
false claims but after tweeting this
comparing covid vaccines to the
Holocaust he was swiftly suspended by
the conservative party with the chief
whip saying he'd crossed a line the
former Health secretary was clearly
angry the disgusting anti-semitic
anti-vaxx conspiracy theories that have
been promulgated online this morning are
not only deeply offensive but
anti-scientific and have no place in
this house or in our wider Society
well can I join with my writable friend
in completely condemning those types of
comments for Martin Stern who survived
the Holocaust and spent his career as an
immunologist the Tweet is both insulting
and wrong
before they opened their mouths about an
issue like this they should inform
themselves they should get expert advice
Andrew Bridgeman has not done that so he
has failed in his duty to his
constituents and to the British public
people here in Ashby de la zouch are
getting used to their MP being in the
news for all the wrong reasons
this is the latest in a series of recent
scandals last year during legal action
against his own family he was accused by
a high court judge of lying under oath
and he's currently serving a five-day
suspension from The Commons for
breaching lobbying rules and then
suggesting the woman investigating him
could have been swayed by a peerage
some constituents question if he should
now remain as their MP it's not giving
Good Vibes that is it to the older ones
that need the vaccine he's got a lot of
good things that he wants to say and
it's never a bad thing to have the
opposition within your own party as well
you shouldn't say there's that so that's
probably why he's been took off it do
you think you should still be the local
MP
not really no
there was no sign of him at his
constituency office we did try to
contact him but he didn't respond he'll
now be formally investigated an MP who
forged a career as an outspoken
backbencher may this time have gone too
far
Becky Johnson Sky News leicestershire